in norway a cultural project is underway
that will benefit generations yet to be
born it's a library that's also a time
capsule each year for a hundred years an
unread manuscript by prominent authors
being placed inside locked away until
the year 2114.
our journey began in a scandinavian
forest with what's become an annual
ritual
deep in the nordmarka forest on the
outskirts of oslo norway
hundreds have gathered from across the
world for an expedition that will take a
century to complete
they've come together to witness the
annual handover of a manuscript that
will be unread and unpublished until the
year 2114.
we join them for this solemn connection
through generations the journey starts
essentially right here in this
very long hike into the forest
it's known as future library launched
eight years ago by scottish artist katie
patterson the core of future library is
time and longevity but also hope and
rituals
it's more important than ever that we
expand our time horizons
[Music]
every year one of the world's most
acclaimed authors is invited to submit
their work a practice to be repeated a
hundred times with only the title
revealed
the manuscripts will be printed one day
on the paper provided by these trees a
thousand of them in all planted for
what's been called the world's most
secretive library
[Music]
among those inaugurated this year in a
ceremony encompassing missed time for
the pandemic zimbabwe writer
and so i am
utterly humbled and privileged to have
been asked to participate in this
the bbc named dakaremba's debut novel
nervous conditions one of the top 100
stories that have shaped the world
she says future library is one of the
most important projects she's been a
part of
there's something about what happened
today that centers you on thinking about
the future too
absolutely and thinking about it now
from the point of view of i am here
today but i am also part of the future
through the actions that i enact today
there is something fantastic isn't there
about writing a book that's going to be
unread for a hundred years
and won't be opened until everyone alive
now is dead
norwegian author carl uva canal scored
whose autobiographical series my
struggle has been translated into 35
languages calls it a dream assignment it
puts into question all the things that
the writer has to think about who are
you writing for why are you writing
monks represented the third author ocean
vog the best-selling vietnamese-american
novelist of on earth were briefly
gorgeous
after the ceremony the manuscripts then
make their way to city center
where they're kept inside the also
public library
housed in the silent room which
officially opened a few weeks ago
authors store their works inside a thick
glass drawer inscribed with their name a
time capsule
patterson helped design the space even
as the creator of future library you
don't know what's on these manufacturers
oh i have no idea of course i want to
know yes but if i looked at them it
would break the spell of the whole thing
with a hundred layers for a hundred
manuscripts the room a vault is designed
to represent the inside of a tree
the wood fell from the future library
forest itself as part of land
regeneration
it's an endeavor with unique support
from the city of oslo is there anything
like this anywhere else in the world no
i don't think so it shouldn't be it's
unique it's an artwork there should be
only one anna berta hovind helped
commission future library what was it
about the idea of the project itself
that made you say we're going to take a
chance on this i like these kind of
challenges
i must admit i come from an old farm 14
generations at least my last name is a
viking name so i'm very grounded i think
our our world is there's too many
short-sighted decision making 100 years
that's not that long either you know
when you when you are brought up on a
farm like that hovind now chairs the
future library trust which selects the
writers everyone asked has said yes
as ambitious as the project is a
promising sign of success came when
margaret atwood author of the handmaid's
tale signed on as the first contributor
we'll be able to communicate across time
which is what any book is in any case
authors have nearly a year to compose
their manuscripts given free reign on
length and genre
no rules except not to share their story
with anyone even an editor or family i
see how the people of 2114
will benefit from this how do people
today
benefit how what do they take away it's
a simple ceremony it's just in a forest
it's just trees and you know it's just
words and paper but it's quite humbling
from the one-click amazon world of like
you know expecting instant gratification
but to always live in that world is
going to have consequences you know
because
our actions affect that future and even
though they seem distant it's our
children's children the library is also
an act of faith in future generations to
be guardians and carry out the project's
final chapters
these woods providing a vehicle of
optimism for the eventual readers of
these books
what do you want them to take away from
this at the end of at the end of all of
this i think
you know it started as such a small
thing but i i just hope people will take
away that in this moment of time
the generation that are being born now
are being born into troubles that
the last generation did not even have to
think about and so i think it's about
leaving something that's hopeful
that saying we see you we respect you
you're not born yet but you're important
to us
and we really hope that by the time you
read this book
some of the problems that we're facing
now
may be sorted out
and they're guessing that with a
thousand of those trees they have enough
material to make about 3 000 copies of
those books and you can buy those
certificates now it helps fund the
project and then pass it on to whoever
you think might get it in the year 2114.
love that
beautiful story it is a beautiful story
thank you
for bringing it to us